hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of book two of the Nicomachean ethics
after he has listed off the various
virtues and their opponents biases
Aristotle also talks about emotions that
can themselves be arranged in relation
to each other
where one would be the mean state as
opposed to other states that would be
the extremes and these these aren't
precisely virtues as such one that he
discusses like that is shame and he says
isn't really a virtue it's more an
emotion but it doesn't have a mean state
he's going to discuss that later on and
I'm not going to talk about that one
here the ones that I am going to talk
about are this spectrum that he lays out
between three different feelings and why
people feel them and whether they're
good or bad to feel so the good one is
what he calls righteous indignation you
notice that your nemesis there that's
the Greek term for this and it means a
becoming upset a feeling pain becoming
irritated and somebody enjoying
fortune who doesn't deserve to so the
reason why we think it you know nemesis
is like this enemy who pursues is
because nemesis is is kind of setting
things right by taking you know taking
action against those who got away with
what they shouldn't have gotten away
with you know the bank robber who is in
his house and never get caught
who's kind of a despicable character you
know when nemesis occurs we think of
that as kind of poetic justice and we
feel a sense of things being set the way
they ought to be that's because we might
be moved by a righteous indignation on
one side is malice a term that you may
have recognized if you've seen the video
states or actions or emotions that are
bad intrinsically and the epic a great
Akio that is literally setting one's
hand to doing bad you know messing with
people just for the sake of messing with
them would be you know one way in which
that happens in terms of action and then
envy so knows this is a term that the
Greeks use an awful lot even talking
about their gods the guys being envious
of mortals we could think of jealousy
sometimes people want a distinctive
jealousy and enviousness is maybe
following into this but but enemies
strictly speaking is pain that one feels
and the for the good fortune that
another person enjoys so you know you're
envious of what other people have that
you don't have and you're envious of it
because you think that it's a good thing
even if you do the summer grapes thing
of saying oh what they've got isn't
really that good anyway if you're
envious detractor deep in your soul and
you may actually do think it's a good
thing and you're pained by that and
Aristotle says that's a sign of bad
character notice that the the
righteously indignant
person also feels pain and other people
enjoying goods but he feels it when they
don't really deserve those goods and
it's really only righteous indignation
if indeed they really don't deserve
those Goods otherwise it's probably envy
hiding itself masquerading itself as
righteous indignation because if you're
if you're upset about anybody enjoying
anything good or anybody who isn't you
enjoying something good you're envious
and Aristotle says that the malicious
person is at the other extreme because
they're not really feeling any sort of
pain as a matter of fact what they feel
is pleasure but they feel pleasure and
other people incurring something bad so
it doesn't have to be necessarily doing
something bad yourself you know the the
malicious person sees somebody fall down
a flight of stairs like you know and
then you say oh they hurt themselves
they shoot their tooth and they're like
man I wish they chipped their hole at
all their teeth I wish they knocked all
their teeth out
well that is a sign of maliciousness so
what we've got here are emotions that
you have to do with pains and pleasures
felt in relation to the good or bad
fortune of other people you notice I've
got some other ones set down here as
well that's because Aristotle talks
about these kinds of emotions in other
places besides the Nicomachean ethics
book - in the indian ethics he talks
about righteous indignation at me they
says there's a nameless emotion over
here where somebody's just like 2 lakhs
and they don't care about what anybody
you know enjoys or you know what happens
to them they're just unaffected in the
rhetoric Aristotle is going to introduce
discussion of two other emotions and
he's going to see that both of these are
indeed signs of good character this is
very interesting one of these is what we
translate typical
as emulation and in this kind of pain
that you feel the Greek fruit is telling
the word would get zeal from right it's
a pain that you feel when somebody else
enjoys it good so it looks like envy
doesn't it but it's not envy it's a pain
you feel when that is the kind of good
that you wish yourself were enjoying but
you recognize that you still have some
work to do before you can enjoy it so
for example when you are starting out in
a profession you see the people who are
higher up in the order who let me use a
great example being on YouTube right I
have quite a few subscribers there are
many channels who have many more
subscribers than me and if I was an
envious person I would anytime that
somebody's got more subscribers of the
eggs that's terrible
they don't deserve it you know I'd be
engaged some attraction instead I might
look to them and say wow that's that's I
wish I were there and it kind of bothers
me that I'm not but I see why they're
there and I'm gonna try to strive to get
to where they are that's what we're
talking about is zeal on the other hand
we have pity lay ups this broad term
that we can also translate it's
compassion sympathy and it consists in
feeling pain and another person's
undeserved pain or perhaps even in some
cases of their deserves pain but
Aristotle talks about his undeserved
pain so where is the malicious person
sees somebody to get hurt and they're
like yeah stick it to them that's that's
great they feel pleasure the person who
feels pity instead says oh I wish I
could help them you know it bothers me
that they're being hurt that they're
being put down the third being injured
so you know for example in relation to
pull the ends the person who feels pity
will feel a sense of pain at the pain
that the other person is being bullied
feels the person who feels malice is
going to you know identify with the
bully and think
great that the other person is being
made to feel pain the person who feels
righteous indignation is going to be
upset with the bully saying you don't
deserve to enjoy that feeling that
you're giving by by hurting somebody
else you know you can see all sort of
the I suppose the envious person would
say I wish I could be the bully the the
the zealous person is not going to want
to be the bully the zealous person would
want to be the person who sets things
right I suppose as so you see all of
these are tied in with our moral life
with how we evaluate other people and
whether they deserve to have a pleasure
deserve to have pain deserve the good
fortune or bad fortune or you know
treatment that they have from other
people these are very important emotions
to our moral existence as human beings
and notice some of them are are by their
own nature BAM envy and malice some of
them are good Aristotle also says in the
udn ethics not in the Nicomachean ethics
that feeling um for example nemesis in a
certain way contributes to the virtue of
justice so I can it doesn't
automatically lead to it but it kind of
leads the way and similarly these vices
lead to injustice so these emotions
whether we feel them how much we feel
them who we feel them in relation to are
quite important and we don't want to
overlook them